bonjour monsieur Orsenna bonjour bonjour
de ce livre la terre à soif c'est chez
Fayard ça a été publié au mois de
septembre et justement on va en parler
de ce livre on va parler de la question
de l'eau puisque 15 ans après l'avenir
de l'eau vous avez publié ce livre
est-ce que 15 ans après quel constat
vous faites est-ce que la situation
s'est aggravée alors c'est frappant
parce que comme j'étais longtemps
professeur de matières premières j'ai eu
envie de revenir à la plus vitale des
matières premières qui s'appelle l'eau
vous savez que 75% de nous nous sommes
constitués d'eau et donc j'ai fait un
tour du monde pendant deux ans et demi
sur l'eau quand je suis revenu donc il y
a 15 ans on m'a dit écoute c'est
sympathique on apprend des trucs mais
une chose est sûre ça nous concernera
jamais tes récits sont exotiques et puis
évidemment on a vu ça donc c'est un peu
ce qu'on a vu c'est-à-dire que c'est
[Musique]
inégalitaire et bien c'est plus pareil
il y a aussi une inégalité de l'eau il y
a la même quantité la même quantité de
de précipitation mais répartis
différemment et de façon de plus en plus
inégalitaire ce qui met notre démocratie
notre République face à des enjeux
terribles comment répartir de façon la
plus juste possible une ressource
essentielle dans une société déjà
déchirée donc c'est non seulement la
question de l'eau mais la question qui
est posée aussi c'est la question de
démocratie comment allons-nous organiser
ce partage et autre question c'est à
dire comment allons-nous voir le long
terme parce que moi le Sénat que
l'assemblée mais nous sommes pris en
otage par le court terme sans arrêt donc
vous voyez c'est pour ça que c'est des
questions qui me passionnent c'est le
sujet de l'eau mais c'est aussi le
symptôme de nos sociétés l'eau est le
miroir de nos sociétés dis-moi comment
je te dirai sans risque d'erreur à
quelle société à quel type de société tu
appartiens et on va parler de la
question de la France mais d'abord cette
gestion de l'eau elle doit se faire
aussi au niveau mondial les pays de
réfléchir ensemble et vous parliez du
long terme c'est aussi le rôle de ces
coques la cop27 se termine aujourd'hui
est-ce que pour vous elles sont utiles
c'est quand est-ce qu'elle pointe les
vrais problèmes est-ce qu'elles
apportent des solutions
très bonnes dans les diagnostics et pas
bonne du tout dans les réponses et pas
bonne du tout dans l'urgence des
réponses vous savez je suis les codes
depuis très longtemps notamment la Coop
de Paris et donc on voit bien que les
États sont au fond un peu un peu
prisonnière parce que les sont
prisonniers pourquoi parce que ils ont
une logique particulière de
développement etc les associations aussi
d'un côté c'est pour ça que ça les les
discussions doivent continuer mais le
rôle des entreprises est clé et le rôle
des collectivités locales et
territoriales clés aussi parce que ce
sont un les souvent des pollueurs et des
ou des gens qui prélèvent beaucoup d'eau
pour leurs besoins tout à fait légitimes
et de l'autre côté quel est le bon
espace où on peut décider c'est ça qui
voyait autrement s'agit pas pour moi
c'est la région la région pourquoi parce
que la gestion de l'eau c'est une
gestion de bassin c'est-à-dire que le
l'écoulement de le long de la loi et de
tout le bassin de la Loire et tous les
affluents n'a rien à voir avec celui du
Rhône qui n'a rien à voir avec la
Garonne et quand j'ai vu un moment donné
qu'on a voulu rogner les budgets des
agences de l'eau qui sont célébrées
partout dans le monde à la fois comme
mode de gestion et comme Parlement
c'est-à-dire comme organisation d'un
partage d'une ressource et bien on
voulait tout
recentrer à Bercy avec cette
foliecumulative de dire à Paris on sait
faire mieux pour moins cher et ben c'est
pas comme ça que ça marche
et l'eau nous donne cette vérité qu'il
faut trouver la bonne échelle la bonne
échelle de l'espace qui me semble bassin
donc en gros les régions et d'autre part
et d'autre part le long terme
selon vous elle est d'une certaine
manière bien gérée grâce à ces questions
là mais
la première la première solution c'est
pas la gaspiller donc évidemment il faut
économiser de toutes les manières
possibles il faut économiser par la
recherche de nouvelles espèces vous
savez qu'on est en train de découvrir
pour le riz une nouvelle variété qui va
permettre d'en consommer trois fois
moins c'est un exemple donc le savoir le
savoir est encore le savoir donc la
recherche encore plus donc ne pas donner
suffisamment à la recherche c'est mal
géré de tas de choses notamment l'eau
donc ça c'est des questions mais j'ai
entendu le le sénateur Boquet parler des
réseaux mais on gaspille 30% de son eau
donc évidemment il faut des fuites sur
les réseaux évidemment évidemment on va
il faut évidemment qu'on investisse donc
vous savez il y a deux façons de faire
des dettes
il y a la mauvaise façon c'est de
dépenser plus que ces moyens et l'autre
très mauvaise façon c'est de pas
investir donc quand vous réhabilitez pas
les réseaux vous plombez tel ou tel
municipalité ou l'ensemble du territoire
avec des dettes terribles des fuites
vous savez ça veut dire que la prise de
conscience sur cette question de l'eau
c'est vrai qu'on en parle beaucoup et on
suit beaucoup de l'actualité via la
presse régionale et c'est à la Une de
beaucoup de types de presse régionale
ces dernières semaines la question de
l'eau est-ce que la prise de conscience
est là pour vous est-ce qu'elle est trop
tardive mais
merci le Sénat je salue le Sénat dans ce
livre parce que le vrai rapport le vrai
rapport qui a alerté sur la question en
France encore une fois par exotique
c'était au Sénat et moi j'avais été
entendu à cette occasion là et je
continue à travailler avec ces sénateurs
parce que c'est eux qui les attendent
pourquoi parce que concrètement il
savait ce qui allait se passer parce que
ça se passe ça se passait déjà vous
voyez c'est ça c'est pour ça que c'est
pour ça que on gère bien que si on est
dans le long terme mais ça veut dire que
au niveau des gouvernements la prise de
conscience n'a été trop tardive bien sûr
que trop tardive ça veut dire que les
politiques publiques ne sont pas à la
hauteur aujourd'hui pour cette question
il y a eu vous avez au Sedan délégation
de la prospective écoutons là
écoutons-la et un commissariat aux plans
qui existent très bien heureusement mais
voilà écoutons là on savait vous savez
il y a une formule
psychologique très étonnante c'est
croire c'est une chose mais croire à ce
qu'on sait c'est autre chose par exemple
nous savons même si je suis mortel savon
que on va mourir si vous savez que vous
allez mourir vous êtes plus doux avec
les gens et vous dites plus je t'aime
aux gens que vous aimez et ben c'est
pareil c'est il faut croire il faut
d'abord pas refuser le réel et une fois
que vous avez accepté le réel il faut y
croire et une fois que vous y croyez il
faut proposer et moi je suis en train de
faire une sorte de tour de France des
solutions et j'ai passé une journée
entière avec le maire de Montpellier et
la présidente de région au Carole Delga
c'est passé
les solutions qu'est-ce qu'on fait
qu'est-ce qu'on fait les solutions donc
une des solutions c'est ce système
formidable qui existe depuis les Romains
de prélever une toute petite partie de
l'eau du Rhône et dans des mécanismes
très subtils de la distribuer un peu
partout pour éviter que l'Occitanie
demeure avec un système de réserve
couplé à ce système de prélèvement parce
que de la même manière que il faut
empêcher de gaspiller de la même manière
qu'il faut trouver de nouvelles variétés
il faut évidemment en fonction de la
géographie en fonction de la géologie en
fonction de l'état des sols il faut dire
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de cette ressource
évidemment en prélevant maximum les
richesses dont dans les zones humides il
y a beaucoup de sujets dans ce que vous
venez de dire on va les approfondir
d'abord la question des réserves parce
qu'effectivement c'est une question qui
se pose est-ce qu'aujourd'hui il faut
plus travailler sur cette question il y
a eu un débat au cœur de l'actualité il
y a quelques jours c'est la question des
bassines pour vous c'est une solution
alors je vais vous dire d'abord il y a
un premier mot pardonnez-moi mais je
suis membre de l'Académie française et
je fais attention aux mots si vous dites
bassine c'est mort
parce que dès que vous dites bassine ça
vous voyez une bassine et donc c'est pas
vivant c'est maintenant voilà donc moi
je préfère retenu je préfère réservoir
parce que dans réservoir il y a réserve
ça veut dire qu'il y a économie
premièrement deuxièmement sur cette
affaire des réserves et non pas des
machines il y a une sorte de religion
qui s'affrontent il y a des extrêmes des
deux côtés il y a des gens disent on
touche pas l'eau et d'autres qui dit
m'emmerdez pas j'ai toujours fait comme
ça vous n'allez pas m'apprendre mon
métier et bien c'est insupportable les
uns comme les autres et il y a nous
avons me disait François brodelle
mimencé storien qui a été mon maître il
me disait il y a 350 pays en France donc
regardons la diversité si vous avez pas
de nappe phréatique en dessous
vous pouvez très bien récupérer une
partie de l'eau quel est l'état du sol
si vous avez des fraisatiques si vous
avez des zones humides des grandes
réserves de biodiversité évidemment
faisons très attention mais faisons une
sorte de bilan
ce que je disais ça c'est-à-dire cette
vision folle française de dire on va
faire la même chose de Dunkerque à
Cayenne mais on est où là écoutons vous
savez il y a une sorte de morgue à
privilégier l'histoire par rapport à la
géographie moi plus ça va plus je suis
géographe et que soyons humbles sa vie
il y a un mécanisme qui m'intéresse bien
l'âge étant venu au fond comment faut-il
se tenir dans la vie essayons d'être sur
terre comme si on était sur mer et là on
salue évidemment ce qui ce qui court la
Route du Rhum qui sont mes héros absolus
trois principes très simples soyons
humbles c'est à dire celui qui est pensé
plus fort que que le climat qui est plus
plus fort que la mer il infréquentable
au revoir déterminez c'est pas parce
qu'il y a du baston qu'on va pas sortir
et 3
soyons soyons dans l'esprit d'équipage
c'est à dire le partage à la bonne
échelle c'est pour ça que vous voyez je
redis cette question d'eau est
passionnante en tant que tel mais en
même temps nous placent face aux défis
de notre démocratie de notre République
c'est intéressant cette question de défi
démocratie mais pour continuer sur ce
que vous me disiez sur la question du
modèle agricole parce que c'est vrai
qu'on pose un peu le débat sur est-ce
qu'il faut produire moins c'est ça la
question vous vous dites il faut pas
forcément produire moins il faut
produire mieux et c'est la recherche qui
va nous aider comment est-ce qu'on peut
dire une seconde qu'il faut produire
moins alors que il y a quasiment un
milliard de personnes sur terre qui
mangent pas à la fin comment peut-on
dire ça comment peut-on dire qu'il faut
produire moins alors que il faut
évidemment que nous récupérions une
sorte de souveraineté alimentaire
comment autant dire ça c'est pas
possible comme les gens qui disent
arrêtons de travailler arrêtons tout ça
soyons dans la décroissance et c'est
avec la décroissance qu'on va trouver de
nouveaux médicaments c'est avec la
décroissance qu'on va inventer des
nouvelles façons de créer l'énergie pas
du tout simplement différemment donc les
gens qui disent on va continuer
l'agriculture comme avant mais bien sûr
que non on va prélever de l'eau comme
avant bien sûr que non on va pas
réfléchir aux questions de de l'élevage
agricole de masse absolue et Dieu sait
si je suis pour l'élevage mais de
manière un peu différente j'ai fait 400
pages sur le cochon donc je connais un
peu ces questions qui ont permis à la
Bretagne de sortir de la misère mais
maintenant il faut envoyer donc
évidemment mais il supprimé l'eau à
l'agriculture c'est supprimer la vie et
qui va manger et qui va manger vous
savez quand on attaque les agriculteurs
alors que le budget consommé réserver à
la consommation et passer de 30% des
ménages à 10% et ben je veux dire mais
quel mépris à qui moi je suis
respectueux de ce que je dois aux gens à
qui je le dois c'est la souveraineté de
la France aussi qui est en danger bien
sûr que oui mais bien sûr que oui et
puis c'est une des richesses de la
France de nos potentiels
sur la complètement oublié mais là je
suis économise vraiment et la balance
commerciale je travaillais beaucoup sur
la balance commerciale de balance
commerciale est complètement effondrée
et si on n'a pas les exportations
agricoles vous savez nos exportations
agricoles ça nous rapporte plus que les
Airbus alors il faut pas se [__] du
monde non plus moi j'ai voyez Dieu sait
si j'aime la modernité donc vous voyez
que de sa vie de fil en fil on pense
qu'on est dans des sujets différents
mais tout ça est complètement lié donc
évidemment on doit aider les
agriculteurs à accélérer encore la
transition
activités humaines et françaises c'est
autant réformé que l'agriculture on leur
a dit produisait produisait produisait
maintenant on dit respecter respecter
tout en produisant attendez et vous
savez quand on donne des sens
agriculteurs qui sont les plus pauvres
parmi les Français les agriculteurs où
il y a les plus de menaces d'inquiétude
qui poussent souvent suicide sellerie
cuticulteurs donc il y a une chose que
je supporte pas c'est le mépris
il y a quelque chose dont on nous avait
parlé c'est l'entretien du réseau d'eau
il y a un autre sujet aussi c'est la
gestion des eaux usées la France est
très en retard sur ce sujet notamment
par rapport à l'Italie par rapport à
l'Espagne il y a un gros travail à faire
là-dessus avec en terme de norme vous
savez j'ai été dans mon premier tour du
monde j'étais à Singapour Singapour ils
sont pris complètement puisque ils ont
pas d'eau du tout donc il recycle tout
et notamment le usé et il recycle l'eau
usée qui sans passer par des des
surfaces naturelles et bu par les
enfants et on appelle ça la new water la
nouvelle eau et donc évidemment on peut
faire ça comment est-ce qu'on peut
limiter toutes ces normes de recyclage
bien sûr il faut recycler bien sûr il
faut s'interroger sur le fait qui est de
réseau d'eau dans les dans les immeubles
le réseau pour le musée tout ça bien sûr
il faut voir ce qu'on fait de la pluie
qu'on peut récupérer pour son jardin
Cette c'est extraordinaire le nombre de
solutions et ce blocage on va rester on
va rester comme avant non le monde a
changé mais il y a des solutions c'est
ça ce que je veux dire c'est que vous
savez c'est aussi une bonne nouvelle moi
quand j'ai fait de l'économie vraiment à
la fin des années 60 toutes les années
70 Paris etc j'avais dans la tête une
ligne la croissance une ligne comme ça
je me suis rendu compte que il y a pas
de ligne dans la vie il y a que des
boucles il y a que des boucles et donc
le recyclage
comment peut-on dire déchets au lieu de
pas avoir dans la tête nouvelle
ressources donc quand vous mettez une
une boucle dans votre tête
c'est pas ça qui m'avait à me rendre des
cheveux mais je veux dire
ce qu'on disait sur les bassines à la
fois on est conditionné par le
vocabulaire et par les images de fond
qu'on a dans la tête notre géométrie
mentale et dans le vocabulaire on parle
beaucoup de sobriété énergétiques en ce
moment est-ce qu'il faut aussi parler de
sobriété aquatique mais bien sûr que oui
il faut économiser mais quand je disais
la recherche économiser les plantes vont
économiser on va pas arroser n'importe
Toucan alors que la plante en a pas
besoin une meilleure savoir encore
savoir quand on sait à quel moment la
plante a besoin quand on invente
d'autres variétés on va donner l'eau
juste à ce moment-là avec du goutte à
goutte avec tout ça donc il y a une
capacité immense et moi je dis pour tout
je suis prof enfin d'abord prof ou élève
perpétuel j'en sais rien mais rien n'est
plus intéressant pour tous les jeunes
qui nous regardent parce que y a pas que
les sénateurs et donc les immortels et
donc voilà c'est travailler sur l'eau
tout est possible vous savez moi ce que
pourquoi je fais ce travail de grands
reporters de fond c'est que j'aime
expliquer j'aime alerter j'aime
émerveiller et j'aime proposer donc
voilà vous avez dit quelque chose de
très intéressant qui est que la question
de l'eau c'est aussi le miroir de nos
sociétés est-ce que dans un futur proche
il faut s'inquiéter pour une guerre de
l'eau est-ce qu'un jour les populations
se feront la guerre pour la question de
l'eau alors d'abord je vois que si c'est
pas la guerre il y a des tensions civil
il y a eu un mort quand même j'oublie
pas le mort de Sivens et donc moi la
capacité d'une démocratie à gérer une
ressource rare elle se trouve posée là
ça a été violent dans les Deux-Sèvres ça
a été violent donc ça c'est déjà il y a
des tensions chez nous il se trouve que
depuis 2 ans j'enseigne à l'école de
guerre quoi la géopolitique la
géopolitique des fleuves pourquoi parce
qu'avant quand on se battait pour un
puits ça mettait un peu d'animation dans
le désert maintenant quand vous avez
deux pays de 100 millions d'habitants
qui se battent et ce qui se passe et
ouais les tensions entre entre l'Égypte
et l'Éthiopie pour un seul fleuve qui
s'appelle le Nil il y a un peu le Soudan
au milieu on imaginez comment ça va se
passer donc il y a des tensions très
très fortes les Ethiopiens ont construit
un barrage juste à la frontière de leur
pays juste avant le Soudan et bien tout
ce qui est en train de se décider dans
le rythme de remplissage du barrage
pourquoi parce que les les Égyptiens ils
sont à 95 millions d'habitants mais les
Ethiopiens y sont sans 105 millions
d'habitants et ils ont le droit l'eau on
leur a jamais permis parce que le
pouvoir était toujours aux mains des
Égyptiens c'était les Pharaons
l'Empire ottoman et les Anglais
colonisateurs maintenant ils disent on a
droit et si jamais les Égyptiens
savaient de détruire le barrage ils
t'apprêt l'Allier principal en Chine de
qui de la Chine parce que la Chine a
choisi l'Éthiopie pour pour y installer
beaucoup de ces entreprises donc c'est
ça l'affaire puis la question des deltas
tous les Delta du monde sont menacés il
y a 500 ou 600 millions d'êtres humains
qui sont menacés parce que il y a eu des
barrages en amont parce que les
mangroves vont les a détruites parce que
on a creusé des trous partout etc bon
alors on fait quoi de tous ces gens là
ouais le banglage mon cher Bangladesh et
ça veut dire aussi des déplacements de
population énorme qui seront liés à la
question de l'eau c'est toute une autre
politique migratoire qui est
150 millions d'habitants au Bangladesh
si rien ne se passe et va nettement on
n'est pas très sûr que ça va s'améliorer
on peut imaginer 50 millions d'êtres
humains sous l'eau vous voyez c'est ça
ce que j'essaie de raconter très
concrètement mais encore une fois le
possible c'est notre noblesse moi je
supporte pas la victime sans proposition
vous êtes très proche des élus
Erik Orsenna lundi va s'ouvrir le
Congrès des mers au-delà de la question
de l'eau évidemment les élus sont
inquiets inquiets pour leur avenir
inquiet pour leur pouvoir d'agir c'est
le thème de ce congrès inquiet pour leur
marge de manœuvre la France est un pays
incapable de mettre en œuvre une vraie
décentralisation selon vous et bien
honnêtement j'en peux plus
j'en peux plus parce que j'étais plutôt
jacobin au début et plus je circule dans
cette France que j'aime de tout mon cœur
et par la langue et par ces paysages et
par ses gens
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible
parce que on donne d'une main et on
retire deux fois plus de l'autre main
donc faut être un peu cohérent dans
cette affaire et dans la continuité dans
les différentes crises qui se
multiplient avec les gilets jaunes ou
avec l'épidémie que je connais bien
parce que je suis au fauteuil de pasteur
ambassadeur de pasteur je vois sur la
place bon qu'est-ce qui se passe il y a
pas les mers vous savez ça fait 10 ans
maintenant que j'accompagne
l'Association des maires de France alors
ils sont considérés qu'est ce que fait
ce Parisien mais je suis pas de parisien
je vais vous dire et puis je vois ce que
je vous dois donc je leur dis on a
chacun sa responsabilité à la vôtre
immense la mienne toute petite vous êtes
élu je suis lu chacun sa responsabilité
mais vous vous êtes à hauteur de gifle
et vous êtes au début et si vous n'est
pas là notre pays se déchirerait donc je
vais une fois de plus leur apporter mon
soutien je passe toute la journée de
mercredi auprès d'eux avec une
admiration infinie et vous le dites ils
sont en hauteur de gifle les agressions
des lieux se multiplient malheureusement
quasiment plus de 50 % ces dernières
années est-ce que c'est le symptôme d'un
affaiblissement notre démocratie pour
vous mais bien sûr que oui avec le
caractère extrêmement néfaste des
réseaux qui cultivent la haine mais il y
a pas que les réseaux il y a certaines
chaînes qui cultivent cette haine là des
médias il y a une responsabilité des
médias pour vous
par tous les médias certains médias
c'est pour ça que je vais vous dire moi
deux manières générale j'aime le service
public et les principalement dans les
médias ça peut conduire ou cette
affaiblissement de notre démocratie pour
vous ça peut amener le pays où ça peut
conduire à une sorte de dictature vous
savez pourquoi parce que il faut que la
démocratie fasse la preuve de son
efficacité son efficacité c'est quoi
c'est le partage et l'inscription dans
le long terme le partage il faut pas
dire il y a officiellement et
ruissellement non on sait bien que le
ruissellement marche pas et que
exactement dans la manière de
répartition des richesses comme la
répartition de l'eau ceux qui sont les
plus riches sont de plus en plus riches
ceux qui sont les plus pauvres sont de
plus en plus pauvres sans classement
moyenne il n'y a pas d'équilibre donc il
y a pas démocratie mais ce qu'on parle
des élus je vais dire je vais me
permettre de lire un passage de votre
livre au hasard sur la chambre des
collectivités sur le Sénat puisque vous
faites l'éloge du Sénat vous dites chien
lectrice cher lecteur puis-je me
permettre un conseil fraternel
lorsqu'une question vous inquiète par
exemple pour nous un jour et former
l'éducation nationale rendez-vous au
Sénat non content de vous proposer une
bibliothèque d'une richesse infinie
cette chambre haute en complément de sa
mission législative organise des
rencontres de grandes qualités car
libres et pertinentes il faut dire que
ces unions de qualité le sens du temps
long et le souci des territoires
j'assume complètement et je suis ravi
que le président de cette Haute
Assemblée soit vétérinaire
et je dois vous dire que
j'ai cet immense honneur d'avoir été élu
comme membres associés à l'Académie des
vétérinaire pourquoi parce que je
m'étais battu pendant la covid battue
pour qu'il y ait enfin un vétérinaire
dans le conseil scientifique vous
imaginez c'était c'était d'origine
animale une épidémie il y avait que des
médecins et pas un vétérinaire donc vive
les vétérinaires
Gérard dernier niveau puisque vous êtes
commissaire d'une nouvelle exposition à
Lyon au musée
fleuves on va voir quelques images vous
nous en dites quelques mots alors oui
c'est formidable on a voulu incarner
vous savez je me disais comment je vais
faire passer ce message mais sache de
l'eau c'est essentiel mais abstrait je
me suis dit bon et bien et bien nous
allons maintenant dire parler des êtres
humains d'ailleurs une rivière un fleuve
une rivière un fleuve on peut l'aimer on
peut la respecter on peut se battre pour
elle on peut raconter l'histoire on peut
tendre l'oreille et donc c'est pour ça
et donc moi je suis aussi romancier vous
comprenez donc je raconte les histoires
c'est par ces histoires que l'amour peut
naître et qu'on peut défendre cet amour
merci Eric Orsenna merci beaucoup pour
cet entretien passionnant et je remontre
votre livre la terre a soif c'est aux
éditions Fayard merci infiniment d'avoir
été notre invité on passe au club des
territoires